Speaker 1: Ukrainian president Volodymyr Zelensky
made a sort of last minute, at least as far
as it was announced, a visit to Washington,
D.C. yesterday, which included an address
to Congress, a an opportunity that not many
foreign leaders get.
And we will talk about that in a little bit.
The speech that Zelensky delivered to Congress
about the help that the U.S. has been providing
to Ukraine in its defensive war due to the
invasion of Ukraine by Russia.
And Vladimir Putin was a good speech.
It was a powerful speech.
And also the entire event had a pretty weird
feeling to it.
And I think I know what the weirdness was.
And I'm going to talk about that in a moment.
Much fanfare and we're going to get to all
aspects of this, but a big standing ovation
to kick it all off.
And what we're watching here, if you're watching
today rather than listening, is Zelensky entering?
Too much applause and a standing ovation and
the greetings of so many different people.
There's Senator Patrick Leahy.
And you see Charles Schumer, the senator,
and all sorts of different people, Zelensky
wearing his typical green.
I don't I don't know that I want to editorialize
the shade of green, but it is not the best
shade.
Not that we really care about that.
It's just a weird, colorful voice in the public.
And here he greets Vice President Kamala Harris
and then the speaker of the House, outgoing
speaker of the House, Nancy Pelosi.
And he delivers a speech and many applause
lines in the speech, including reminding the
world and the United States that Ukraine is
not out of this thing against.
Speaker 2: Against all odds.
And doom and gloom.
Scenarios.
Ukraine didn't fall.
Ukraine is alive and kicking.
Speaker 1: And another standing ovation there.
And of course, it is great that Ukraine has
been able to resist what some characterized
and handicapped as an easy win for Russia
when this started months and months and closing
in on a year ago.
That is an absolutely great thing.
We now get into the part that I believe was
the element of weirdness, which is that there
was a feeling of this, that it was sort of,
okay, we're going to give you the money.
New aid package, around 2 billion, including
Patriot missiles.
We're going to do it.
But you've got to come here and you've got
to really thank us and you've got to act extremely
solicitous towards us.
And that was absolutely a big element of this
speech.
Speaker 2: I'm glad to read that President
Biden supported our peace initiative today.
Each of you, ladies and gentlemen, can assist
in the implementation to ensure that America's
leadership remains solid.
Bicameral and bipartisan.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: And, of course, it is not actually
completely bipartisan.
And that's part of what's interesting about
this.
There are people there are Republicans who
are sort of.
Soft supporters of the U.S. helping Ukraine.
And then there are people like Matt Gaetz
and Lauren Boebert who are flat out just against
American help of Ukraine.
And they sped into the House chamber at the
last minute and sat there looking visibly
bored, never clapping as a deliberate show
of how against this they are Zelensky assuring
and reminding everyone in the chamber that
the money we are sending to Ukraine is not
charity.
It is part of the goal, shared goal of global
security and democracy.
Speaker 2: Financial financial assistance
is also critically important.
And I would like to thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for both financial packages you
have already provided us with and the ones
you may be willing to decide on your money
is not charity, right?
Is an investment in the global security and
democracy that we handle in the most responsible
way.
Financial financials.
Speaker 1: Okay.
And this ultimately led to a Ukrainian flag
actually being unfurled on the floor of the
House.
Speaker 2: Let this flag stay with you.
Ladies and gentlemen, this flag is a symbol
of our victory in this war.
We stand, we fight, and we will win because
we are united.
Ukraine, America and the entire free world.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So now what's happening is Zelensky is unfurling
a Ukrainian flag, which is now being held
up by Nancy Pelosi and Vice President Kamala
Harris.
And then similarly, you might see off to the
right of the screen that there is an American
flag in a triangle shape.
And then that was handed to Zelensky and off
he went with his American flag.
And now this is the end of the speech and
we see Zelinski leaving with his American
flag that was handed to him.
So, listen, my feelings on this are very mixed.
Of course, I support Ukraine.
And of course, I believe that it is in the
interests of the United States and our allies
to beat back the invasion by Russia.
Putin's a lunatic authoritarian.
I mean, listen, I've got a decade of commentary
on this.
There is absolutely no question there.
This entire visit, extraordinarily heavy on
the theatrics, which I feel repelled by the
theatrics to a great degree because it is
such a stage managed event.
But public opinion, particularly global public
public opinion depends on exactly that stage
management.
And so while I personally find it offputting
as someone who follows this stuff all the
time, I have to be open to the idea that for
people who are busy working in fields that
are not political media, their opinion about
what should happen may actually be shaped
by events like this.
And maybe they want to see Zelinski come and
grovel a little bit.
Maybe that's what they need in order to be
okay with or to continue seeing support of
Ukraine as a worthy cause.
Now, the history of speeches like this to
Congress during conflicts by world leaders
of other countries, it's not the longest list
in the world.
And we know, of course, of Winston Churchill's
address to Congress during World War Two as
the Prime Minister of the UK.
We know about Lech Walesa's address to Congress
during the Cold War.
As President of Poland.
We know about Nelson Mandela's address to
Congress during the apartheid era.
Mandela, the first president of South Africa.
And we have I may be missing a couple, but
we have Havel's address to Congress during
the Velvet Revolution, the last the last and
final president of Czechoslovakia.
How does this compare?
How does the situation in Ukraine compare
not only on the facts, but in terms of its
relation to the United States?
I don't know that I have that answer.
And it may require, looking back from some
future point, to really fully understand that.
But a powerful speech, heavy on theatrics
that I think was sort of determined to be
necessary to continue justifying to some degree
in the court of public opinion the support
to Ukraine that the United States continues
to give support, which I widely am in favor
of, while recognizing that those are dollars
for what is effectively speaking a proxy war
against Russia doesn't make it bad.
In fact, it's the right side.
This was a war of aggression by Russia, but
much more complicated than any simple explanation